et maintenant je vais aller retrouver la
star de la rentrée
michel houellebecq quartier du blanc
je veux montrer qu'il cherchait à savoir
de man bien méchant pourquoi ce
désespoir fond de moi
je me sens mal je suis le maire de nay
jean-marc onesta je veux montrer jaloux
et soir merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde non pas en même temps compte tenu
de ce que vous dites dans votre bouquin
au sujet de la concurrence ça aurait été
difficile d'y aller non non je pu
effectivement jeu oui je suis dur et
fuji elle mais il met le mérite alors
vous publié chez fayard la possibilité
d'une île donc c'est l'événement
littéraire médiatique commercial de la
rentrée votre livre écrase d'ailleurs
cette cette rentrée et les 650 autres
romans de la rentrée sont un peu réduits
au rang de figurants non oui mais c'est
pas de ma faute
j'avais dit longtemps l'avant ce que je
publie un livre plus beau là j'ai décidé
de
d'arrêter de faire de la fausse modestie
parce que ça se verrait donc c'est vrai
que mon livre est bon
oui c'est un peu normal qu'il écrase la
rentrée oui c'est pas de ma faute je
veux dire totalement s'est déclenché
beaucoup d'années dans tous les cas non
bah oui mais ça aussi c'est normal on
peut pas on ne peut pas en vouloir au
moins la jalousie est un sentiment
humain que je comprends parfaitement
avec lequel je sympathise même et que je
suis toujours prêt à pardonner
alors au delà du phénomène houellebecq
on va parler du livre d'abord le pitch
donc la possibilité d'une île raconte la
vie de dalian qui est un être humain qui
viennent pas vraiment à notre époque un
qui vit dans une dans une dizaine
d'années à peu près oui oui oui oui les
quelques légères augmentations de
phénomènes déjà visibles comme mauvais
traitements aux vieux ce genre de choses
ce qu'on a vu apparaître dans la
canicule de 2003 oui oui les l'effarante
inhumanité en phase avec les quais dans
laquelle on finit ses jours quoi le pi
l'islamisme est moins moins présent dit
c'est un peu comme le punk
c'était très fort c'est redescendu et
maintenant pour garder une comparaison
musical c'est un peu comme la new wave
quoi oui oui
ouais ouais bon s'appeler thermidor ça
peut apparaître bien optimiste mais
enfin c'est ce que je pense c'est sa
main ça m'est venu à l'esprit en voyant
des défis très voilé ce que le but
c'était de faire peur craint un peu
comme le but des pins qui essaie de
faire peur aux gens normaux manqué en
les filles ont toujours dévoilement fins
et plus décoratif vous dites oui oui et
puis bon tout ça tout ça s'efface pop
donc je parie sur un sur le fait que les
choses se calment et qui est bon par
l'intermédiaire de
de la jeunesse un geek envie de liberté
d'une race aussi alors ce dernier elle
vit donc en 2015 à peu près et sa vie
est lu et commenté
deux millénaires plus tard par ses
clones des néo l'humain que vous appelez
daniel 24 et daniel 25 alors eu en fait
ils ont pu besoin de se nourrir et vivre
par photosynthèse
oui je ils ont juste besoin d'eux comme
les plans de sol minéraux et d'eau et
ils ont beaucoup moins bon à part ça il
ya des il ya des mâles et des femelles
comme les vives sol reliées par
bon internet franchement améliorée et
ils ont un entraînement qui consiste en
gros d'abord à faire des exercices pour
eux obtenir la paix le calme
l'absence de désir et de souffrances
dont quelque chose de très inspiré du
bouddhisme
par ailleurs il étudie la biographie de
leurs prédécesseurs
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils étudient la
vie de daniel 1 pour essayer de tirer
parti de leurs échecs et de leurs
souffrances pour ne pas vivre la même
chose alors daniel hains donc celui qui
vit dans dix ans c'est un humoriste à
succès un mix entre eux dieudonné bigard
pierre desproges
mais quelque chose de pire que tout ça
réuni parce que il est d'un cynisme
total et sert que dieudonné je pense que
c'est pas purement de la provocation
chez lui je pense qu'ils croient
vraiment à la cause palestinienne est
malheureusement qu il est peut être
aussi devenu antisémites du coup alors
que daniel lui les prêts a allumé tout
le monde du moment qui pense que ça peut
être marrant et d'une misogynie
affolante
il ya cette fameuse van tu sais comment
on appelle le gras qu'il ya autour du
vagin la femme
oui oui oui et il est misogyne mais il
est une espèce de
il est toujours sur le fil du rasoir que
ça c'est un bon pro très très bon procès
y provoque mais ça reste juste à temps
il gagne plein de fric
ouais à un moment il rajoute un petit
peu d'anti sémitisme parce que ça
puisque c'est bien alors il fait un film
porno qui s'appelle brut/mois la bande
de gaza tombereaux leur longe et donc
ils essayent toujours de surfer quand
même pour rester politiquement correct
dans le politiquement incorrect
si on cela que c'est une légère
anticipation parce qu'on est
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle il y
aurait une espèce de carton rouge je ne
sais quoi mais je suppose que le
l'humour qui a déjà beaucoup de droits
beaucoup mais c'est un peu n'importe
quoi vont en gagner encore un peu plus
et lui se moque de tout ce qui
l'intéressé c'est quoi d'ailleurs c'est
le succès ce qui est terrible c'est que
malgré ses dérapages racistes misogynes
finalement il a une bonne image auprès
de la presse il a des bonnes critiques
dont elle dit vous des bonnes critiques
dans le télérama il passe pour un homme
de gauche
oui mais il réussit pas mal aussi de
des gens d'extrême droite vous dites
qu'en fait que le le seul contenu
résiduelle de la gauche c'est l'anti
racisme oui mais c'est vrai que la com
com contenu de la gauche abandonné il ya
eu enfin on peut s'en souvenir il ya eu
comment dire une société partageuse quoi
mais tout ça complètement disparu la
gauche est devenu libéral
ensuite il ya eu il est resté une espèce
de libertarisme mais c'est fini c'est la
gauche et anti drogue antitabac donc
balle est la seule cause sur lesquels
bas ce qu'ils font quand même des causes
un peu mobilisatrice offert sur lesquels
on arrive on arrive à mettre d'accord la
gauche etc c'est l'anti racisme que vous
appelez le racisme anti blanc oui parce
qu'il ya une sorte de au fond de désir
désir de pas être blanc faye et cette
culpabilité manipulatrice et un peu
louche mais donc il arrive à sa propre
surprise est encore considéré comme un
homme de gauche et même comme un
humaniste et pourtant des droits de
l'homme et s'en fout il dit quand aux
droits de l'homme rien à [ __ ] à peine
si je parviens à m'intéresser aux droits
de ma que oui c'est un type finalement
qui a écrémé dit vous tous les créneaux
porteurs le racisme la pédophilie la
torture le cannibalisme le parricide
avec un certain succès donc oui et à 47
ans il est complètement lessivé l'on
peut plus le type les consciences de
conscience de sa propre médiocrité où il
a conscience d'être de [ __ ] quoi être
d'être plus d'être plus habile de pas
alors il a 47 ans il est lessivé vous
dites la vie commence à 50 ans c'est
vrai à ceci près qu'elle se termine à 40
quoi donc à 47 il et il est bon il tient
il tient limite quoi enfin il en a il en
a marre de ce qui fait ils en aient
marre de son public qui supporte plus le
rire ce qui est quand même grave pour un
comique c'est c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose de méchant dans le rire et
moi si j'ai déclaré c'est vrai que
j'avais beaucoup été impressionnée par
quelqu'un qui était naturel chaleureux
ouvert et qui avait connu de funès et
comme on lui demande de parler de de
funès voit son visage change et regin
dit ah oui lui les est vraiment triste
et c'est impressionnant parce que de
funès et le comique le plus gentil le
plus tout public qu'on puisse imaginer
il semble bien que quelqu'un qui arrive
qui arrive à être comique celle qui
s'est mécaniquement comme on peut faire
rire les gens qui a trouvé succe ce
secret là ce soit un secret triste parce
que la smat objets de très bien
connaître la nature humaine
oui on est obligé de très bien connaître
nature humaine on s'interdit d'exprimer
tout événement peut être vu comme
comique ou comme tragique aussi ont vu
mon service interdit d'exprimer le côté
tragique et apparemment se finit par
vous rendre volume très triste alors
donc lessivé il se retire en espagne
dans une maison de 27 pièces au nord
d'almeria mais tient pas du tout compte
de la beauté du lieu ça au cas sauf
qu'un effet sur lui
e
il s'aperçoit que ça suffit pas que le
lieu peut être beau mais n'y peut rien
en faire en fait de cette de cette
beauté il dit à un moment donné que s'il
avait un réel tempérament artistique il
pourrait faire quelque chose cette
beauté des tableaux je ne s'est pas
prononcé pas le k way gens qui
s'ennuient et il vit donc avec isabelle
qui est une rédactrice en chef d'un
magazine de mode qui s'appelle lolita
voilà mais il s'ennuie parce qu'il n'a
pas envie de faire des enfants
non il n'a pas envie de faire des
enfants il n'est pas pourquoi parce
qu'il veut pas imposer finalement à
d'autres êtres le calvaire d'une
existence terrestre ya un passage où
c'est vrai je me suis moi même posé la
question pourquoi les pourquoi les bébés
hurle à ce point alors ça arrive pas du
tout
aux bébés chats chiens et un cochon et
je pense qu'il ya un défaut quelque part
peut-être c'est une erreur de perdre les
poils
enfin je sais pas mais bon là ça là
c'est le côté de la science fiction
commence à arriver ici quelque chose qui
va pas d'hellemmes pas les enfants ils
disent l'enfance est une sorte de nains
vicieux d'une cruauté ine et d'ailleurs
les animaux domestiques en en peur c'est
vrai que l'enfant manifeste sa
personnalité sa volonté de dominer son
entourage de manière violente
mais pire que ça au fond sicile eurent
le bébé c'est parce qu'il souffre je
pense réellement qu'on est trop sensible
la douleur que la douleur physique va au
delà de sens de son sa nature de signal
et il ya quelque chose qui va pas au
fond on sent que quelque chose de
déséquilibrer dès le départ chez l'être
humain
alors daniel et isabelle ne font pas
d'enfant et le grand événement c'est
quand il recueille un chien un dénommé
fox soir au bord d'une autoroute et là
vous dites c'est le meilleur amour c'est
l'amour inconditionnel parce que
finalement le chien il attend rien en
l'échangé vous aiment vraiment oui puis
et puis ce qui est assez bon tout le
monde toute personne ayant vécu en
couple c'est qu'il n'est pas forcément
facile le rendre heureux le conjoint
alors que le chien c'est possible mais
s'ils ont animé des meilleures
intentions du monde le bonheur de
l'autre n'est pas garanti alors qu'avec
un chien ça peut arriver
et en fait ah ben ça arrive c'est assez
facile de réussir la plupart des maîtres
y arrive c'est beaucoup un
vous êtes heureux avec clément oh oui
parce que je sais qu'il est heureux et
donc j'ai ce pouvoir là ouais vous
rendez quelqu'un fouille
nous devons être heureux alors qu'avec
un enfant ça serait pas aussi évident
c'est pas aussi évident
en plus l'éducation plus facile
concrètement c'est éduquer plus
rapidement alors entre daniel et
isabelle l'amour physique s'étiole
rapidement lui ce n'est au pastis
tranxène c'est quand la faim coltel
parfaitement houellebecq ja oui bon
c'est une vie c'est une nuit
particulièrement dur où il s'aperçoit
que en fait elle aime pas vraiment
l'amour physique j'ai dû jouer ça pour
lui faire plaisir mais elle aime pas la
jouissance parce qu'elle est le problème
d'isabelle dans ce livre c'est qu'elle
est un peu trop noirci elle a été très
très très belle elle encore pas mal du
tout et vous savez les gens qui sont
trop beaux finalement parfois du mal
avec l'amour physique parce que ça les
déforme un chez clyde il est mieux
offrir une image admirait weepu offre
une image glace est calme
la beauté va toujours avec une certaine
froideur quand même et là c'est terrible
pour lui parce que lui c'est ce qu'il
préfère c'est celle là c'est la seule
chose que dans la vie le motive encore
et isabelle paris la trompe pas c'est ça
qui la trompe pas du tout elle part
parce qu'elle sent qu elle en train de
se dégrader physiquement et précipite
ses propres dégradation pour une
surconsommation 2.3 elle prend 20 kg
provins kg 1
mais au départ c'est elle qui laisse
tomber ouais c'est ça qui est selon lui
très malheureusement il tombe sur une
dénommée esther nous appeler la belle
qu'à 22 ans et qui va lui rendre la vie
par le sexe quoi on comprend qu'il a ce
monde sa vie où on commence à en vivre
ce qui va être un bonheur total il sait
qu'ils veulent perdre il sait aussi que
ce bonheur est si fort que sa perte
veulent tuer cirque et esther est
vraiment
il s'engagea dans sachant que c'est sa
dernière histoire alors vous avez des
phrases formidable la vie sexuelle de
l'homme se décompose en deux phases la
première où il éjacule trop tôt la
deuxième vous larif lui a bandé et le
problème de daniel avec esther c'est
qu'en fait ils se retrouvent dans la
première phase en fait il éjacule trop
tôt donc y trouve une crème oui ils
retardent les actuels et comptant déjà
il est content de revenir les premières
fois le premier prix les glaces heures
bon en fait mais il ya de grands moments
de bonheur dans ce livre m avec le staff
est là il trouve une crème qui
oui on fait des choses maintenant quand
même faut pas nier le progrès technique
pour retarder le régulation et donc s'en
suit une période de bonheur très intense
et puis et puis l'assaut s'étiole parce
que les vieux ce qui est évident c'est
que quand il peut lui faire ce qu'il
veut à cette fille mais chaque fois
qu'il veut l'embrasser sur les lèvres
elle se détourne un peu commune comme
une prostituée et un moment elle doit le
présenter à sa soeur et elle ne lui
présente pas sa soeur parce que parce
qu'il est vieux donc lui se rend compte
de sa wii face skis ce qu'ils
craignaient ça se vérifie et puis là
mais quand on est vieux on a eu plein de
soucis dans sa vie en faire courir vous
amuse qu'il peut pas il veut faire
partie de son groupe de jeunes s'est pas
en fait c'est pas le sexe
qu'est-ce-qu'il case danse histoire
ouais c'est le fait que simplement il a
plu l'énergie la l'enthousiaste ont fait
il est il est trop sage trop troussage
vous ne pas trop résignée trou trop
vieux ils vous dites dans le monde
moderne
on pouvait être échangiste bi trans
zoophile sm
mais il était interdit d'être vieux et
les jeunes que c'est le début de sa vie
amoureuse c'est tout et lui c'est la
faune voir le problème c'est qu isabelle
n'aime pas assez le sexe et esther
n'aime pas assez l'amour voilà c'est
tout le dilemme pour ester l'amour c'est
c'est un divertissement avant tout y'a
pas d'un d'implication personnelle
penser que ses propres aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
il est possible que l'amour soit mort
que ce soit après dieu ça fait 2-1
oui ça fait beaucoup je sais pas si les
jeunes ont envie d'aimer ou pas je peux
jeune je peux pas
ouais prononcer mais alors là c'est
terrible parce que donc plus d'isabelle
plus d'esther et la plus que son chien
dans l'ombre fox et il se réfugie chez
les elohim it
alors c'est une secte évidemment
directement inspirée des raéliens et ça
vient d'une histoire insensée c'est que
dans la bible
s'appelle elohim qui est un pluriel et
qui veut dire les anges
et effectivement depuis de nombreuses
années et à vandaele avant claude
vorilhon il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
dit qu'en fait le dieu de la bible
c'était les elohim les anges c'était des
extraterrestres bon ça c'est le début
c'est le début du dogme ne sait plus ou
moins rendu compte que ce qui était
accordée aux extraterrestres à dire le
pouvoir de créer et de manipuler la vie
les hommes étaient en train d'y arriver
au même un techniquement sans sens
extraterrestres et donc la grosse
promesse là hello i meet est en fait la
promesse classique des religions s'est
rapporté à tout le monde l'immortalité
et la jeunesse éternelle
ouais vous dit que c'est une philosophie
très adapté au monde moderne parce que
d'abord une grande permissivité sexuelle
à l'intérieur de la secte et ensuite
elle promet une immortalité palpable
enfin c'est pas une mentalité spirituel
c'est une immortalité physique
en fait oui voilà il n'y a pas besoin de
croire grand chose d'extraordinaire et
s'est adaptée aux progrès techniques
vous dites qu'une religion c'est une
secte qui a réussi mais vous dites
sérieusement ah bah oui mais ça c'est si
on voit les choses honnêtement si on
voit le départ des religions c'est vrai
que ça se présente vraiment comme une
secte c'est à dire un petit groupe
dissident par rapport à une religion
une grosse religion dont ben al'inverse
on ne peut pas prévoir c'est une secte l
heure actuelle on peut devenir une
religion de grande diffusion
vous le connaissez real oui toi de vos
rayons mais il est sympa oui plutôt et
un cri rue louis ii est allé le voir
vous avez étudié
oui vous avez vous allez passer du temps
avec les raëliens pourrait faire vote
libre évidemment pour étudier mais aussi
parce que vous êtes intéressé réellement
barça mais je suis intéressé par les
parures religion en général 1
et là je vais faire fait une secte qui
soit pas complètement grotesque à dire
comme ces gens qui croient que l'oignon
correspond symboliquement à différents
stades de développement enfin quelque
chose qui qu'ils puissent quand même pas
être immédiatement ridicule et leurs
histoires de clonage va parce qu'il ya
deux ans ils ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
ou qu'ils avaient réalisés à un clonage
humain
elle a par contre j'ai franchement des
doutes c'est vrai que aussi dit toute
façon on n'est pas loin des rives mais
vous dites toute façon tout ce que la
science permet sera réalisé oui ce qui
ressort du livre quand même un michel
sait si vous avez ni respect ni
compassion pour pour l'humanité croyait
même une haine de l'humanité et même je
dirais une haine de la part d'humanité
qui est en vous avant vous l'humanité
les misérables et les humains quand on
lit votre bouquin on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu des mammifères dans
un zoo dans le fameux parc humain
en même temps ils sont sympathiques
c'est tout c'est toujours ça il n'ya pas
bon c'est comme dans plusieurs de mes
livres y ait pas de nier pas de vraie
solution c'est le désir n'est pas une
solution mais le nom désir non plus donc
passés ces mammifères auquel vous
réduisez les humains vous dites sans
quête de sexe de fun et finalement vous
dites à moins de qui tu médites ce sont
des kits se définit-il monsieur eric est
plus que dès qu'ils disent plus ou moins
vieux way
ils ont que bon ça c'est foutu je veux
dire il y aura plus de il y aura plus de
dignité à la vieillesse faux pas il faut
pas y compter
ça n'arrivera plus parce que tout ça a
perdu son sens et sa reposait sur un
système de succession des générations de
choses à transmettre sa s'intégrer dans
une religion qui chapeautait le tout
donc ça on le retrouvera plus plus
jamais alors ça se vend bien la
possibilité d'une île non plus exempts
des 300 par jour chez virgin le davinci
code à la meilleure époque en vendée
soixante dix par jour et amélie nothomb
50 content quand même
ah oui oui je suis content oui ça
m'effraie un peu le scan and it avec le
devine chi code mais bon je suis content
ouais ça se vend bien s'est traduit dans
36 pays
vous êtes déçu par l'accueil de la
presse française finalement non parce
que nul n'est prophète en son pays c'est
ce genre de choses c'est basique mais
c'est vrai qu'on en veuille je comprends
je vais pas j'ai pas je vais vouloir
être aimée en plus oui vous ne croyez
pas que les journalistes on était énervé
par le fait qu'ils aient très peu de
gens qui a eu le bouquin qui eut cet
embargo sur votre livre bon c'est vrai
que si des gens au bout de trois
articles écrits ce que des conneries sur
moi ce mois béni l'envoi une quatrième
fois je veux dire il ya des gens qui
meurent jamais ouais vous avez très peu
d'interviews cette rareté des interviews
c'est une une façon de vous protéger
contre vos dérapages en vue du prix
goncourt
non c'est pareil il ya des gens qui se
paient le coût de produits
bobby façon je veux dire si je faisais
énormément d'interviews mlle
reprocherait aussi j'ai l'impression que
je suis à un stade ou quoi que je fasse
ce sera d'abord perçue comme très très
mal un rôle à la caisse qu'il force one
bank
il fait énormément interview genre
qu'est ce qu'il est fort il fait rien
donc autant que je fasse ce que je
refuse c'est à dire faire des interviews
que les gens à qui j'ai envie d'en vous
remercie mais c'est vrai que par exemple
le figaro c'était très dur avec eux vous
avez dit que vous refusiez désormais
d'une interview au figaro pendant la
durée de votre vie littéraire non mais
là c'est un peu exagéré il ya eu des
mises en cause même pas sur le monde moi
parce que moi c'est aussi un signe
évident de gens de ma famille avait des
trucs que j'ai pas voici le ferai pas
honnêtement vaut aussi pour les i treva
ce qui est drôle c'est qu'il y avait des
publicités qui était passé dans le point
dans l'express dans le figaro vous avait
annulé et vous avez gardé seulement la
publicité dans le chien de ville riche
en 2000 le message insisté pour avoir un
chien 2000 c'est bien si un ami mais
pour les pour les maîtres de chiens
c'est la meilleure revue avait il ya
d'excellents dossiers techniques sûr on
est ni au courant dès qu'il ya une
nouvelle un nouveau parasite ouf rien en
sauvage combien sérieusement ça vous
fait quoi de pas être reconnu comme le
grand écrivain que vous êtes michel
houellebecq
je suis pas inquiet sur l'avenir du
l'avenir du jugement sur les livres
c'est pas vrai que c'est un juste un
phénomène commercial selon main ce livre
sera lui longtemps
non je suis rassuré vraiment merci en
est heureux de vous voir heureux est
maintenant interdit aux apps haidar
alors michel houellebecq qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce moment
c'est sûrement que j'ai des dents qui
tombe parce que là j'ai un truc
temporaire ouais
et si celle ci ça tombe avant que j'aie
le temps de refaire un truc définitive
et je vais beaucoup merdé dans les
lectures c'est va siffler je fais des
lectures en public j'adore ça quel
compliment qui vous énerve le plus je
crois que c'est peut-être quand on me
dit que je suis gentil quelle est la
qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir alors
c'est sûrement l'impossibilité de mentir
parce que moi ça m'a alors le carrément
littéraire moi ça m'a qu'est-ce que j'en
ai bavé dans les émissions oui on est
sommé de dire son avis sur le livre des
autres on pense du mal c'est horrible en
écrivain pardonne jamais comme de
démolition public
quel est le talent que vous avez mais
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir longtemps
je retrouve trop intelligent et jeu mais
c'est à dire que j'envisage trop de
possibilités quoi quels défauts
aimeriez-vous avoir eu je sais pas si
c'est un défaut j'aimerais bien être
plus plus primaires plus instinctif plus
immédiat
on dit que vous êtes radin c'est vrai
euh non ça je crois que c'est pas vrai
ouais je sais pas pourquoi on dise aux
gens simples millions de nairas plus je
vous dit que c'est pas vrai qu'ils ne
voudriez vous pas avoir comme fans
j'aimerais pas tellement avoir grillé
comme fans
bon ça me ça m'inquiéterait bon le
nouveau roman vous en pensez quoi
ensuite la maire d'embrun a carrément
carrément il ne reste rien par qui
aimeriez-vous être détesté b j'aimerais
bien que les écologistes répondait mais
agression permanente
j'aime pas tellement le
la pensée écologie ça me dégoûte un peu
mais j'ai beau agressent les écologistes
s'ils réagissent pas pourquoi ça vous
dégoûte parce que je suis resté très
baudelairien chercher tout ce qui est
naturel on ne trouve rien que d'affreux
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait c'est
peut-être une critique de julian barnes
sur plateforme way qui a dit quoi
en gros je fais je fais trop de
concession à l'émotion facile quoi je
perds un peu d'insolence bonnes
critiques
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour arriver à vous séduire
maladroite ça marche toujours moi je me
souviens une du bon en fait j'ai pas
j'ai pas du tout sa valise était une
histoire d'amour par la suite mais une
une stallone scott et la première fois
que ma vue était très ému de me voir
parce que je tenais en hauteur elle
renversait carrément la bouteille de vin
sur - fossat adorable ils étaient
pressés vous avez souillé bon ce qui a
évidemment fait nuit s'est rien passé
mais le la maladresse oui qu'est-ce que
l'avenir ne dira pas sûr vous ne dira
pas si j'ai été heureux ou non ça
restera indécidable jusqu'au bout
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez jamais dit à
personne c'est déjà je vais te tuer
ouais parce que
ce que je pense que si je l'avais dit je
l'aurais fait est que j'ai eu envie mais
mais non j'ai l'intégrer l'interdît
moral de meurtre a été le plus fort
ouais
quelle est la question qu il ne faut pas
que je vous pose et se serait peut-être
qui je vais parce que j'ai pas ce que
j'aurais des réponses et que j'ai envie
d'oublier
en fait j'ai envie d'être way s'apaiser
de d'oublier je crois pas ou je crois
beaucoup au pardon c'est un concept
assez un chrétien je passais chrétien
mais j'ai envie de vous croyez plus à
l'oubli que pardon oui honnêtement oui
et ça concernerait votre mère par
exemple ça pourrait mais il ya d'autres
personnes mais justement c'est les
questions n'en parlons pas merci très
heureux merci beaucoup michel je me sens
gens me reconnaissent tels que je veux
montrer des pompes qui cherchait à
savoir de ma vie mes choix et pourquoi
pas chez moi
[Musique]
sur les apparences
michel houellebecq
puis c'est le mille
m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu